All over India and Southeast Asia.
They write with these squiggly loopy Hangie,
sprouty scripts,
but perhaps the only thing cooler than the way they look.
It's the way they work.
A spice market in India.
The hooded figure in front of you apologizes for the kidnapping.
He needs her help.
He explains that his land has taken part in history's most elaborate and
rigorous memorization exercises instead of scribes.
They had recitations.
These weren't retellings of campfire stories.
These were whole libraries of knowledge handed down for generations.
He says his name is Ashoka.
This is his land and he is king.
After a bloody and violent war.
He had a change of heart and now has but one singular focus to spread his
message.
A love tolerance and compassion throughout the land,
but he doesn't want to use the mouth to ear memorization ways of the oral
tradition.
That's for old pets and old ideas.
No,
his vision is to install massive pillars around his empire.
Each one engraved with his list of edicts.
This he explains is where you come in.
See He's been keeping tabs on you as you roamed the land of the submitted odd
jobs.
And he really likes this crazy consonant alphabet idea.
He'll take it.
But he also appreciates the whimsical simplicity of accent and consonance with
vowel marks.
Oh.
And he doesn't want to have to write the vowel if it's just a short,
uh,
his language is full of those.
So he'll write funnel something like this with these built in syllables,
but wait,
it's not funnel.
Uh,
that final,
oh,
isn't a separate syllable.
He needs a way to write,
just bear consonants to tell his past,
apart from his pasta.
How with a simple hush stroke below the letter.
Now he brags to you,
his system is complete.
Make sure you don't miss the step he's taking here.
It's a major moment in the history of writing.
Each of the character units fundamentally represents a syllable.
It just so happens that unless the vowel and not syllable is a short,
aw,
the val gets added on to or below or beside the consonant character on their
own,
the base characters contain that dummy vowel,
ah,
like puff.
But you can take that and modify it with any vowel.
You light.
Certain bowels go in certain places like e to the side or Ooh below,
so in India characters or syllables,
but unlike a full ciliary,
you don't need a completely separate character for each separate syllable and
all characters give consonant plus vowel information,
but unlike a full alphabet,
you don't line up sequences of consonants plus vowels,
consonants,
plus vowels.
The hybrid combination nature of this system earns it.
The name Alpha syllabary combos are built into this system,
paving the way for over a thousand ligatures commonly linked characters in the
Alpha Ciliary.
Sure.
Other writing systems developed ligatures and their calligraphy,
but the Alpha ciliary welcomes them naturally as it's past all around this
entire slice of the world up to Nepal and Tibet down the coast to Burma,
Thailand,
Laos,
Cambodia,
and beyond.
The script keeps updating its look,
but continues to capture consonants and vowels accurately like an alphabet and
to write those vowels,
consonants,
and syllable units like the syllabary,
even completely unrelated,
Alpha Cilla.
Barry's seize on this same idea.
This is the Ethiopic symbol for ma.
This one reads May and this is Moo.
This is La Ley and loop.
Now that you understand that was still the berries.
You must answer this next question.
If this symbol sounds like blah,
how do you write bay and Bu and Ethiopia?
This is your Gig is a,
B,
c D's.
The [inaudible] Gita looks different,
but works much the same way.
Your characters have never looked so different even after the Greeks and Romans
took them over.
Maybe it's this dizzying variety of writing systems or maybe thoughts.
Pill is starting to wear off.
Okay.